Hey, I'm Luke.
I'm traveling around with my friends...
...and we've got a lot of good tips for you on your travel in Africa.
In Africa, everything is relaxed...
...so adapt and enjoy.
Don't forget to bring a hat and sunglasses.
So remember to bring a headlight;...
...you will see how to put on makeup...
...or find a toilet or eat or anything else.
The nights in the deserts can be very cold...
...therefore don't forget warm clothes.
So make sure you bring enough money...
...because they have good local beers, man.
Don't forget to take a plug for the African plug sockets...
...otherwise you can't recharge your material...
...like your video camera or your photo camera or your mobile phone.
If you go to Africa, don't forget about your camera.
There are loads of stuff to take pictures of.
You know, take the big thing with you.
Remember to bring your binoculars so you can see the animals better.
I am a guide.
When you come to the bush, you need a guide like me.
I can show you some animals.
I can show you the directions of the delta.
Don't forget to check if there is malaria in the area you are traveling to.
You cannot get lost when you are with me...
...'cause I'm the guide in the delta.